i remember that when i when i first
found
your stuff
it was
out of an earnest attempt to try to like
fix and save the relationship i was in
and it was specifically around like
there's no clinical term as far as i
know for daddy issues so it's kind of
like a jokey term
um but it's still real like it's every
bit as real as anything else
and uh
like my ex-girl had had a lot of
problems with her biological father i
think he legally disowned her and her
teens
uh still hung around and was saying why
or is that like too
i don't think i even really know like
that's how crazy it was she wouldn't
talk about it i remember when we would
have conversations she's like as long as
i live and as long as we're together
regardless if we're it doesn't matter if
we're together forever you're never
allowed to have an opinion about this
really
oh yeah she said to me verbatim she's
like you're never allowed to discuss it
with me you're never allowed to say
anything about it like you need to
full-on like you just need to shut up
about it like you can't ask me anything
share like a quick story that has total
relevance to what you're talking about
there because um i've only dealt with
that i think
once in any like significant capacity in
my life which was my single mummy you
know like one itis back in the day um
after i got divorced i was with that
chick for like three years and it was a
very similar type of situation she had
zero relationship with her father in
fact she hadn't talked to him in like 20
years and even changed her surname to
her mother's surname
um so here's why i go that far but it
was very similar like she hadn't spoken
to him forever he would text her every
birthday she wouldn't answer like that
he didn't come to her college graduation
like none of that [ __ ] yeah like that's
like that's a big red flag if if
you as a woman can't have a good
relationship with your father in my view
and it was just like
i didn't see the relevance of the time
because i was a plugged in you know
blue-pilled alpha sort of thing like
this was
almost 10 years ago yeah because it's
coming up on 2012 2013 or so and um
i just didn't see the relevance i was
just like oh well that sucks um i
remember like one time i said something
along the lines of like what would you
do if he if he drove all the way here
because he lives something like four or
five hours away i said what would you do
if you drove all the way here and
knocked down your door right now and you
went answered it and he was there and
she didn't really have like much to
say except for like her face just
dropped just like
you just get these like weird vibes and
[ __ ] you know what i mean oh yeah anyway
i didn't want to hijack your story but
yeah no but i mean it's a great point
and i didn't know what it is what's up
welcome sorry
all right he's in the kitchen he's
thought he's still coming i hear
clanking of utensils
[ __ ] you guys hey
i'm talking about
mother tongue don't talk about
all right i mean new york strip stick
having eggs we're up at nine o'clock
well no one of the things i've noticed
since i joined one percent is a lot of
the guys who are successful and on their
game are up early on the weekends yeah
just an observation
every day
around seven for me man i uh
yeah it usually just looks the latest
it's just the way my my sleep schedule
works my body works so it's like it
doesn't matter if i go to bed at 10
doesn't matter if i go to bed at two i'm
up at seven so it's uh smart too no but
i might my point off is a lot of blue
pill plugged in guys were all 2 a.m last
night spending 300 on alcohol eating
crack food and now they're uh
in bed i'm not saying it doesn't happen
to us every now and then but um yeah as
i i've mentioned a bunch of times that's
that's what a lot of people are told
good time is
totally
muff finish the story on the oh yeah so
i mean what happened was it's like look
my my desire to help was
is how do i help fix this it's how do i
be the fixer how do i save a girl with
daddy issues how do i uh be a good
quote-unquote partner and this and that
and i started just i was watching a lot
of youtube at the time i was working
from home and i was working like
you know i was [ __ ] around mostly
because i didn't like my job and
we were
my industry was highly affected by uh
the scam democ
so
uh i had a lot of free time and so the
video i came across was three women to
avoid dating and the number one was
daddy issues and every word was like
speaking the gospel man it was like this
makes so much sense
it's like
everything that i try to do up to that
point it didn't matter how virtuous i
was it didn't matter how i tried to lead
or how
good of a guy i was she was
incapable of appreciating it respecting
it
uh and desiring it because she had never
had a good example growing up of that in
a man she was
raised in a household by her mom who was
a constant player of victim uh she saw
firsthand that this guy and like look
like as far as i can tell and as far as
i only go about what she tells me as far
as i can tell this guy was a real piece
of [ __ ] it was real [ __ ] yeah i don't
know any different
um that's her story and
i don't know the flip side
um
but
you know
it could have very well been true
but
she was also in therapy but it was the
kind of therapy where it was like i'm
gonna come and cry once a week and not
ever do anything with the advice or help
that i was to get
uh so it was just this toxic spiral and
then i kind of realized that this was
unsalvageable
um
and then i started diving in man i
started watching old stuff i started
reading uh i think i read the rational
mail first because your book wasn't out
yet this was like in the fall of 2020. i
i think i actually bought the unplugged
alpha on christmas day which is just
kind of like
ironic and kind of funny and it's funny
because bert bought it the day after and
he has a better story than i do about
buying the book
um but i've been watching your stuff so
much at that point i i kind of you know
obviously the book is great and uh i
know a lot of your stuff it was mostly
out of support but
um
but yeah and then we had that
conversation with jd mccabe when he came
on your channel but uh it wasn't until
the following week on with aaron
when we were discussing when he was kind
of like he was pushing the book of
numbers
that we had had that good like 15 minute
conversation so and then i think that
night immediately i joined the community
because i was like
one of the things about
this breakup that made me realize i was
like dude i don't have anybody like my
friends had left new york i didn't have
a tribe i didn't have a group of men i
didn't have guys that i could talk to
and confide in um i was like dude like
i was just like i looked around i was
like i got nobody and uh
like the community um it's still kind of
crazy to me to even think about it i was
talking about this with with uh
you know this girl last night and
i was like it's just nuts to kind of see
where i've gone from beginning to end i
was actually talking to 50 shades of the
other day
and i have people that are dming me on
instagram like dude like what do you do
for work like how are you traveling all
these places what are you going to do
and all this cool [ __ ] like are you
[ __ ] involved in the yet this or that
and
you're like man
i'm just like i have [ __ ] awesome
friends and i do cool [ __ ] all the time
it's my life now and it's funny because
i just ran down the list of things
that this community
has allowed me to do and partake in that
i never would have been a part of
otherwise like we did a meet up at a 20
million dollar house
and mansion in miami and i i rode in an
r8 in a ferrari we went to nashville and
i looked
on stage with a live rock band i got a
guy coming down to tampa where i'm going
to live and he's like hey i'm taking you
to a bucks game and we're going to go
deep sea fishing right we're going to
jackson hole with literal
killers
and and doing mma and shooting guns and
have like
went to the heroes trip in toronto like
road in the [ __ ] mclaren like stuff
that i just never would have been able
to do
if not for this so when guys honestly
mclaren is a lot faster than the ferrari
right claire was the [ __ ]
don't let it be uh don't let it be
unknown mclaren is off so
when guys are like oh what do i get out
of the community here like what's it
gonna do for me and it's like it's
almost an insult i'm like dude you have
no [ __ ] idea yeah you said like
you're either in or you're out like yeah
hey guys i really hope that you enjoyed
that short clip if you did consider
supporting the creation of content by
checking out my supplement line pinned
in the top comment below of this video
in the comments there's a link to the
unplugged alpha dot com forward slash
shop when you click through you'll be
able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational essentials
for health immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching i
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out
you